I'd love to get your opinion on why are
there so many different theories of
everything I mean there's Wolfram has
one our mutual friend Eric Weinstein has
had one uh Garrett Lisi I mean they seem
to proliferate and these are very very
you know legitimate ideas some of which
are are very creative Stephen Wolfram
has a completely different approach from
the geometric approaches of people like
Lisi and Weinstein uh why don't you
attribute first of all the the
upsurgents in interest in new and
theories of everything and it's a
natural Frontier and people have
different ideas for how things should go
some some ideas are more developed than
others and
and have had uh I mean yeah like of
course the final Arbiter of any idea is
uh to make a definite experimental
prediction that you know it could be
falsified and or basically a prediction
that you could go and check
that this area has and there have been
no predictions like this for from any of
the theories um but along the way some
some theories have had more predict or
let's say mathematical predictions or
predictions for other years of physics
or some interesting more interesting
structure
and some are consistent with these
principles of the 20th century physics
that I discussed and some are not so
um
for example it's not clear whether
Walgreens ideas are consistent with the
principles of Relativity and causality
and so on time doesn't it's not
and uh
yeah so
um
yeah I think the for those of us that
work on string inspired ideas the what
we like is that it's a theory with
well-defined rules and well at least in
some regimes where you can do
calculations and it's compatible with
this general principles
2010 Century physics and when we look at
some of the questions are coming up
about connections between Quantum field
Theory one of my listeners or whose name
is Rust in Peace who is a frequent
contributor on the channel is asking uh
whether or not the black hole
information Paradox shows that Quantum
field theory is incomplete in other
words do we need a fundamentally new
Theory to merge quantum mechanics and gr
as illustrated by the black hole paradox
yes I think I think I think that's right
um but it's incomplete when when gravity
is dynamical so when the effects of uh
when the effects of the finance of the
Newton constant is is important so
and then others are asking about you
know the perceived I get this a lot you
know failure of string theory to you
know come up with this but I think I
think you've already sort of addressed
this that it may be sort of too much to
ask for or maybe not phrasing the
meaning of the word theory of everything
and and maybe there's too much
expectation of things like uh String
Theory so what's your current appraisal
of the of the State of Affairs and
string theory for example well I think
uh String Theory I view it the mainly as
a candidate theory for quantum gravity
and uh it's a theory that's been fairly
developed and has a very interesting
mathematical structure and has led to
um
interesting connections between Quantum
field Theory and gravity or between
different Quantum field areas and
Quantum filtering on those matter and
quantum mechanics and
thinking about yeah quantum mechanics
and space-time in general and
if
but yeah the fact that there isn't a
concrete experimental prediction is a
problem and uh
I think
we we understood that the landscape of
possible there was a roadmap for example
experimental predictions in the late 80s
which was well we'll we'll have we have
this very nice 10-dimensional Theory and
we'll find the internal space on which
it's compactified so six dimensions are
small we'll find the possible shapes
there will be a finite small number of
possible shapes will uh we'll find which
is the one that gives the standard model
and we'll be able to calculate things
that was the roadmap
um
that roadmap
turned out to be uh well it was more
complicated than expected because there
were many many possible shapes and many
the number was so big that it's very
difficult to study them them all or
study them in a way that you could
really make a concrete prediction the
current thinking is that the
the just in into to explain or
accommodate the cosmological constant
you need to to uh
to exploit this complexity and and so
so the typical like the typical so if
you take an off-the-shelf uh internal
space uh you will get the cosmological
constant which is too large
so the idea that the current idea well
among all the one there are so many that
one will have the right cosmological
constant but that also makes it very
difficult to make a concrete prediction
but I mean people are some people are
are still
um well they're definitely many people
are trying to make statistical
predictions so maybe you don't know
exactly which of the vacuum where we
live in or which but making perhaps
statistical uh predictions of what that
landscape sometimes called the string
landscape of what that landscape looks
like I personally think that also this
uh connection between gravity and and
quantum mechanics
maybe can lead to a different kind of
prediction a different kind of uh
connection between the these ideas and
and the rest of physics and concrete
physics which is the uh perhaps quantum
computers and maybe
Quantum experiments in the lab of
building something some systems some
complex ideas that very complex systems
behave uh in a way that can be described
by a certain space-time and it's not our
four-dimensional space-time but maybe
some auxiliary two-dimensional
space-time and so on and there are
people thinking more actively about how
to get these ideas to to work